britney spears has been faced
with a decade-long nightmare a
kafka-esque nightmare orchestrated by
her father
and others
and i'm so proud of her
for her courage
her strength
and her poignancy
and i've only been on this matter for a
couple of months but i'm proud to say
that we've gotten to know each other
very well
and she's so pleased and she's so
thankful to all of you
and i am as well
[Applause]
[Music]
in terms of what happened today
i'm so pleased and proud to say
jamie spears
is no longer a conservator
[Applause]
jamie spears
has been suspended
and he will be formally removed shortly
jamie spears and others
are going to face even more serious
ramifications
for his misconduct
i said at the outset that my firm and i
were going to take
a top to bottom look at what jamie
spears
and his representatives have done here
that's already in process
and it will continue for as long as it
could possibly do that
to get justice for brittany matthew fans
were shouting jail jamie now do you
think that your investigation into jmu
will lead to criminal charges
i used to work for the justice
department i don't anymore i don't have
that kind of power
but i suspect law enforcement and its
law enforcement's decision not mine
will be taking a hard look at what the
times uncovered and reported on
september 24th and i fully believe
that that is why
and i believe just
judge penny agreed with me
his lawyer was fighting so hard against
suspension
what happens now as a result of him
being suspended
is he is obligated under the law
to turn over his files
to the temporary conservator
those files are supposed to also consist
of
attorney-client communications
those attorney-client communications are
in other words between mr spears
and his lawyers
it's a cliche but one question we're
going to be asking
in regard to mr spears's representatives
not just lawyers or what did they know
and when did they know it
in regard to eavesdropping
putting a listening device under britney
spears bed in her bedroom
something is very very troubling that's
something that it is for law enforcement
and not myself to make the ultimate
conclusion on but my firm will be
looking into it
i'm very proud of the work that my firm
and i were able to do i think the
difference is
i'm a former federal prosecutor
i'm aggressive
i'm very proud that i pledged and maybe
went out on a limb
on july 14th when i was hired that we
would move aggressively and
expeditiously
to remove jamie spears
we filed our petition about two weeks
later and here we are today it's been a
lot of hard work
it's been intense
i'm proud
brittany's proud matthew have you talked
to brittany and what did she say about
her father's removal today i don't get
into attorney-client communications
without the help of this free britney
movement i think the support of the free
britney movement has been instrumental
and to the extent that
it allowed my firm to carry the ball
across the finish line i thank them as
well
i do want to go back to i want to go
back to something i mentioned before
the attorney-client communications
between mr spears on the one hand
and his lawyers on the other i believe
will reveal
corruption
in that regard and that's something that
we look forward to vigorously looking
into
and as important
as important as this matter is to
brittany
and it is monumental to brittany
because this is a substantial step
toward her freedom matthew other than
jamie is there anyone she's free today
she's free today in a sense
just to finish the point
but there's a larger issue here
and the larger issue is now being looked
into
by state legislatures throughout the
country certainly in california
and by the united states congress and to
the extent we can shine a light on that
issue as well
that's something that's very important
all together today
that's not for me the entire
conservatorship
i believe at this point that is
inevitable
matthew
[Music]
today was the major challenge and i'm so
proud to tell you as you know that
britney
because it's about britney not me
met and surpassed that challenge the
challenge today the goal today
was to suspend jamie spears
that's what today was about and that's
what happened in court today
we expect the ultimate termination
will be as i said in my filing of
earlier this week this fall
specifically
by november 12th which is the next
hearing day matthew earlier this year
brittany said she wanted to sue her
whole family could anyone other than
jamie face ramifications that's not
something i'm going to comment on right
now
where do you see brittany's life going
from here as she talked about what she
might want to do when this is over in a
month hopefully she's got a great future
ahead of her
sorry
she's in great hands
is up to her
her future in terms of if and when she
performs again is the decision that
britney and only britney will make
and that's an important that that's an
important point because for so long
for so long decisions were made for her
that's a decision that she and only she
will make
and that's the way it will be going
forward
why was this allowed to continue for so
long
what happened before wasn't on my watch
but that's something that i believe the
united states congress and the
california legislature may be looking
into it
not something i'm going to comment on i
want to thank everybody for coming out
for your support
it was a great day
you